and kamu has this quote
it's ascribed to him it's like a meme
i've never found the source so maybe he
doesn't really say it
but he says maybe it's not about happy
endings maybe it's about the journey
and i think when you have that mindset
and as you and i i think you and i both
found this
because neither of us when we were kids
thought we'd be doing this
right but now that we are really
fortunate
definitely this yeah and definitely that
yeah but now that we're fortunate enough
to do this
and that we're blessed enough that
there's people who find this of value
and interest
and we could pay the rent doing this
there's not a day that goes by
where i don't think you and i or think
this is pretty absurd
yeah but it's also pretty wonderful and
as a consequence of us
thriving it also shows other people that
happiness is possible
on this earth and i think cynicism is
the lie
it's not just the worldview it's a lie
that happiness is not
possible in this earth or it's only
possible
if you sell your soul and you're like a
bad person you screw
other people over i reject that in
every aspect you know as you said my
birth is coming up i've been feeling
um just a lot of really great things
have been happening very very
recently so it affects me very heavily
emotionally especially when i see
the response it gives to uh
like the kids right so it's one thing to
say this is what i'm for
but when you can provide proof of
concept that what you've been advocating
does result in positive responses i got
a message from this kid
who had tried to kill himself a year ago
okay and then he
was like look i found your work i found
some other stuff and now i realize i'm
gonna make something of myself i was
born in a meth house
you know whatever 19 20 years old i
should be in the garbage
but i'm gonna try to be a stand-up
because i have opportunity on this earth
even if he fails as a stand-up you know
he's still
such whatever he does washing dishes
there's no shame in that
he could is it so bad to have a crappy
job
and a girlfriend who you don't really
like but as compared to the alternative
of like i'm gonna kill myself this is
heaven well
i think there's beauty to be discovered
in all of it and all of those
experiences yes
so but at the same time
so i often think about i just recently
re-read the idiot by destiusky
i often feel like the idiot that's why
when i say i'm an idiot i often think
about prince mishkin
that kind of idiot which the world sees
you as naive i don't think he's naive i
don't think i'm naive
but i tend to see the good in people and
the good in every moment
and the world often
is cynical and in fact especially in
what we do
often the intellectual is supposed to be
cynical
this is very much an urban uh elite
educated mindset where if you write a
book about someone who's let's suppose a
drug addict or a prostitute
that has heft and that's valid but if
you're writing a book about
like a love story you know two people
love and it's they're in roller coasters
or
carousels that's less legitimate i hate
that i hate that i hate that so much
because the message it gives to people
is you have to choose between
thriving and happiness and silliness and
seriousness
and depravity and i'm not saying a drug
addict approaches to pray but they're
basically their world views if it's
unless it's dark and twisted
it doesn't really count as art and i i
despise that mindset that subtext
so the internet and people around me
often will call me naive
because i don't think the word they want
is innocent don't you think it's about
it's not that innocent
no but innocent in that you you
genuinely in your heart i know you
fairly well at this point
believe that goodness is possible and
that
people can if not be good at least be
better than they were yesterday
see even the word naive or the word
innocent presumes that there's not
wisdom in that
presumes that somehow that's uh
oh isn't that beautiful to live that
life of a child
who sees the world with these bright
eyes and is hopeful about the future
but just wait until they grow up and
realize that reality is much harsher
than they think
right but that child might be wiser than
all of the adults in the room and don't
you don't you want to be
if the world is like that don't you want
to be the guy who takes it on and
changes it for the better
right so it's like saying well you know
cancer's everywhere it's inevitable
well don't you want to be the one who
says not anymore i'm here and i'm going
to make that change
and i can see it being better than it is
now
so i i i think you and i have the same
analysis of your world view and i don't
think that there is a good
word for it so i guess it's this idea of
you know inherent benevolence might be
you know maybe wordy
but i think that's more accurate because
you know you and i did not have such
easy lives
growing up to put it mildly you
constantly talk about
um just horrific aspects of life so to
claim that you kind of don't know that
they exist or you sleep on the rug is
completely not accurate
to your work and your mindset
you